today we're talking about psvr 2 details
naughty dog teasing secret projects and
more
speaking during sony ces 2022 briefing
this week naughty dog's neil druckmann
teased the company's upcoming games and
said quote we're dying to share with you
the multiple game projects we have in
the works at naughty dog he didn't have
any more to share but one of those games
is likely the last of us multiplayer
project that has been in the works for
some time naughty dog confirmed in 2019
that the last of us part 2 would not
ship with a new version of the faction's
multiplayer mode and instead naughty dog
said it was creating a standalone
multiplayer game in the last of us
universe since then fans of factions
have been slowly dying inside as the
weight just gets longer and longer
pray for us also during the event sony
revealed playstation vr 2 and a new
entry in the horizon series called
horizon call of the mountain and while
playstation ceo jim ryan didn't go into
too much detail about what the device
looks like he did reveal some of the
functionality let's dive into the main
bullet points psvr 2 offers 4k hdr 110
degree field of view and foveated
rendering with an oled display players
can expect a display resolution of 2000
by 2040 per eye and smooth frame rates
of 90 and 120 hertz with inside out
tracking playstation vr2 tracks you and
your controller through integrated
cameras embedded in the vr headset your
movements and the direction you look at
are reflected in game without the need
of an external camera thank you
psvr2 sense technology combines eye
tracking headset feedback 3d audio and
the innovative psvr 2 sense controller
to create an incredibly deep feeling of
immersion headset feedback is a new
sensory feature that amplifies the
sensations of in-game actions from the
player for example gamers can feel a
character's elevated pulse during a
tense moment or the rush of things
passing by your character's head or even
the thrust of a car going really fast
and as for horizon call of the mountain
the game is being developed by gorilla
creators of the acclaimed open world
action series and fire sprite a studio
that sony acquired in 2021 and is formed
of former members of its now defunct
liverpool studio personally i'm a quest
2 player and only had the playstation vr
for maybe 2 or 3 days but i'm really
excited about what the playstation vr 2
is doing it's all the right pieces in
the right places the controller seems
interesting resolution tracking the one
cable thing
i'm in i'm in
but in some non-playstation news rainbow
six extraction is coming to xbox game
pass and pc game pass on day one january
20th ubisoft's chris earley said the
decision to bring extraction to game
pass at launch is meant to demonstrate
how ubisoft sees the value and choice
that game subscriptions offer to players
ubisoft also announced that its
subscription service ubisoft plus is
coming to xbox quote soon this offering
includes a catalog of more than a
hundred ubisoft games along with other
in-game content and perks and just to be
clear this is a separate subscription it
won't be bundled into game pass like say
ea play is but either way let me know in
the comments if you're excited and if
you're excited about playstation vr2 or
even the projects that naughty dog's
working on i know they said they're not
gonna make a uncharted five but they are
open to other studios making uncharted
games so what if what if
we see an uncharted on playstation vr2
ah maybe all right let me know
[Music]